et à tous je m'appelle françois saltiel
je suis journaliste pour l'émission 28
minutes sur arte si vous ne la
connaissez pas c'est que vous êtes
jeunes parce que je vois que ça rassure
dévale certaines et certains ménages
moyens de cette émission c'est 62 ans
voilà art et si vous ne regardez
en tout cas vous pouvez surtout être
curieux et donc connaître cette émission
est mon travail au quotidien sur arte
c'est d'essayer d'anticiper anticiper ce
qui va faire l'actualité en essayant de
la raconter avec un tout petit pas de
côté c'est ce que j'essaie de faire tous
les jours anticipez aussi ce que le
public aurait envie de voir ou de
découvrir et pour faire ce travail
mon terrain de prédilection ce sont les
réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux vous
les connaissez ces applications qui sont
rentrés dans nos vies sans crier gare et
qui parfois deviennent des monstres
incontrôlable l'évolution de facebook
est frappante ans cette plateforme créée
par mark zuckerberg en 2004 qui en un
peu plus d'une décennie est passée d'une
sorte de copain d'avant plutôt
divertissant sur laquelle on s'amuse à
poster des vidéos de chats qui se
lèchent les babines à un site et un
véritable média d'information puisque
c'est la première source d'information
des 15 34 ans facebook on l'a accusé
d'avoir joué un rôle déterminant dans
l'élection de donald trump
on l'accuse aussi d'être un agent
infiltré d'intox pour les russes vous
l'avez compris on est un tout petit peu
plus loin et autrement que la vidéo des
chars moi j'ai encore en mémoire des
images les images impressionnantes mais
qui sont plutôt passée inaperçue c'était
facebook en 2016 lorsqu'ils ont lancé
leurs applications facebook live
eh bien ils ont diffusé la bataille de
mossoul
en direct la bataille de mossoul en
direct sur facebook avec les sharks qui
explose au gré des petits coeurs envoyé
par ici ou des petits pouces envoyé par
là vous imaginez comment cette
plateforme diffuse la guerre en direct
on a appris récemment aussi que facebook
allait lancer sa crypte aux monnaies
donc vous l'avez compris un facebook
c'est à la fois un
site de rencontre un média d'information
une chaîne d'information continue et
demain une banque
alors évidemment cette évolution là pour
le marketing est majeur c'est à dire que
les marketing a fait des réseaux sociaux
une arme machiavélique pour essayer
d'anticiper à nous nos attentes nos
goûts ce qu'on aimerait acheter nos
désirs
les fameuses publicités ciblées sur
facebook par exemple ils anticipent eux
qui pourrait être notre ami ils
appellent ça une suggestion
la suggestion l'algorithme de youtube
l'utilisent aussi si vous aimez un clip
de benjamin biolay
vous aimerez un clip de vincent delerm
et au rêve seulement au passage besoin
d'une boîte de xanax mais ça c'est
encore autre chose
vous l'avez compris le marketing arrive
à cultiver le fantasme grâce aux réseaux
sociaux d'établir une sorte de publicité
sur mesure alors j'ai un dernier exemple
qui va peut-être vous amuser voir vous
effrayer qui vient de la silicon valley
un exemple qui pousse le cynisme au plus
haut point de l'anticipation ça
s'appelle the spinners connaissez de
spinner alors the spinners c'est une
entreprise un site qui vous promet pour
moins de 30 dollars d'arriver à
manipuler le cerveau de vos proches
exemple vous voulez que votre cousine
arrête de boire car à le boire un peu
trop vous voulez que votre fille renonce
à acheter scooter ce scooter parce que
vous avez des appréhensions sur sa santé
et sa sécurité ou encore voulez que
votre fils de 15 ans arrête de fumer et
bien vous pouvez passer par ce szpiner
qui va envoyer un message apparemment
anodin par sms à votre cible
une fois que cette cible aura cliqué sur
le message un mouchard à va s'activer
qui valent à traquer qui va suivre tous
sont littéraire de navigation et comme
par magie sur son fil facebook
ce fils par exemple va rencontrer des
articles comme fumer c'est has been ou
alors attention fumer peut nuire nuire
aux troubles fin peut susciter des
troubles de l'érection
enfin vous voyez faire des choses qui
peuvent vraiment touché les ados en
plein coeur bref c'est des centaines de
messages qui vont arriver
180 message en trois mois un véritable
matraquage éditorial dans le but bien
sûr d'influer sur le comportement de
votre proche pour qu'il arrive à changer
bref c'est une machine à laver le
cerveau
alors on n'a pas encore d'un 10 réel sur
la qualité et finalement la pertinence
l'efficacité d'une telle pratique ce
qu'on sait par contre c'est qu'on
connaît la demande numéro un qui est
demandé et qui est initiée sur szpiner
elle provient des hommes qui veulent
relancer leur vie sexuelle en couple oui
relancer leur vie sexuelle leur libido
avec leurs partenaires
donc du coup celle-ci se retrouve
bombardé d'articles du style 10 astuces
pour retrouver l'amour au lit avec son
mari le plaisir du sexe longue durée
depuis longtemps la fidélité bien sûr
argument numéro un voilà pour le spin r
là ça fait rigoler mais mais quand même
ça nous interroge et puis surtout quand
on questionne de son fondateur sur
l'éthique 2 e szpiner eh bien il nous
répond il se targue même de nous
répondre qu'il offre à l'usager lambda
les mêmes outils qui sont utilisés
depuis des décennies par le marketing
qui bien sûr lui constamment essayent
d'exploiter notre temps de cerveau
disponible essayent d'exploiter notre
comportement essaye de nous faire
changer de suscité des désirs des choses
dont on n'a pas forcément besoin et lui
dit voilà le marketing utilisent depuis
longtemps les politiques aussi je donne
juste cette technologie à l'usager
lambda
alors heureusement on peut espérer mieux
pour l'usager lambda et c'est d'ailleurs
tout le sens de mon propos moi je suis
pas venu ici cet après-midi pour sombrer
juste dans la force obscure de la force
des réseaux sociaux
non je vais aussi exploré avec vous la
face lumineuse des réseaux sociaux car
il y en a une et vous savez justement
quand est ce qu'elle se perd 7 face
lumineuse et bien lorsqu'elle ne sentent
ici pas lorsqu'il ya une sorte
d'alchimie une sorte de magie qui
s'opère entre une cause et un public et
pour réunir justement cette cause et ce
public
il y a un outil il s'appelle le hashtag
le hashtag vous le connaissez tous je
parle du hashtag militants celui qui
engage les gens le hashtag a été créé
d'ailleurs par un usager sur twitter en
2007 lorsque twitter était tout nouveau
tout le monde parlait dans tous les sens
y avait pas d'organisation et chris
messina qui était un ingénieur de chez
google s'est dit tiens et si on prenait
ce croisillons le croisillon donc c'est
la forme qui n'est pas radiés c'est la
forme du hashtag qu'on mettait un petit
mot à côté pour que les gens puissent
parler de la même chose au même moment
c'est un ingénieur il n ya que les
choses soient carrées donc il arrive
comme ça à trouver cette idée de
croisillons et du coup l'idée tellement
pertinente que twitter va l'intégrer
dans son ergonomie le hashtag et puis
facebook va le reprendre et puis un
stage va leur prendre et tout le monde
leur prend jusqu'à aujourd'hui jusqu'à
même aujourd'hui avec le hashtag tedx
boulevard gambetta théâtre du périscope
bref utilisez plutôt en à chaque cours
c'est plus efficace ce hashtag c'est
quelque chose d'assez merveilleux en
tout réfléchi puisque ça veut dire qu'à
chaque instant si on est muni d'une
connexion internet et d'un profil
facebook ou twitter fin surtout twitter
on peut parler de quelque chose on peut
rencontrer son public
le hashtag c'est comme un salon un salon
de conversation et quand je vous disais
que ça ne s'anticipe pas qui aurait pu
imaginer que par exemple lors des
révolutions arabes de 2011 les jeunes
allaient se servir de ce hashtag de ces
réseaux sociaux dans l'angle dans
l'angle mort de la censure et du régime
pour mettre en place une révolution
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux qu'ils ont
utilisés un hashtag pour pouvoir
s'organiser pour pouvoir se rencontrer
pour pouvoir se mobiliser et c'est ainsi
qu'on est passé d'un mouvement virtuel à
une révolution physique dans l'espace
réel
encore une fois quand je lisais dans
l'angle mort du pouvoir et du régime
c'est qu'à ce moment-là facebook ou
twitter et est doté sur tous les trucs
de chats dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure on pouvait pas imaginer que
c'était un endroit où aller se fomente
et où aller se préparer une révolution
plus proche de nous la faire harvey
weinstein fin 2018
avec évidemment le hashtag btu vraiment
jeune ça fait plaisir avec le hashtag
mis tout essayé essayons même ensemble
d'imaginer ce qui se serait passé sans
les réseaux sociaux la faire éclater
elle sort avec le new york times new
york times or donc cette affaire de viol
d'harcèlement sexuel du producteur à
vérines stein on en parle c'est sûr aux
états unis même à l'international
et puis trois semaines après on passe à
autre chose on en a déjà des exemples de
grands scandales sexuels de même
envergure qui ont éclaboussé les états
unis et qui ont fait trois semaines ou
un mois d'actualité qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on parle encore de mitu aujourd'hui
et bien c'est grâce au hashtag c'est
grâce à la population et en l'occurrence
les femmes qui se sont approprié ce
phénomène pour pouvoir dire moi aussi
pour pouvoir dire attention le
harcèlement sexuel des violences
sexuelles
c'est pas que l'eau des actrices
américaines ça me touche à moi
moi aussi je les ai vécus moi aussi je
le vis peut-être aujourd'hui au travail
et du coup je vais le dire je vais le
dire moi aussi avec ce hashtag cd
millions vous imaginez des millions de
témoignages qui ont circulé dans le
monde entier aux états unis en france en
europe au moyen-orient au japon un
véritable tsunami une véritable
libération de la parole comme on l'a
appelé mais aussi une libération de
l'ecoute ça aussi permis à certains
hommes de se rendre compte déjà de
quelque chose que peut-être leurs amis
leurs femmes leurs compagnes leur soeur
leur fille leur avait jamais dit ça leur
a peut-être permis aussi de changer un
peu de comportement alors évidemment il
ya eu des dérapages on a parlé de
délation etc
il ya eu des dommages collatéraux mais
je rentrerai pas dans ses détails et
dans ce point là aujourd'hui
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir comment
avec un simple hashtag est avec ce mythe
où on a pu prendre conscience ou la
société a pris conscience des violences
sexuelles qui était à l'écrit exercées à
l'encontre des femmes et c'est évident
que si on parle encore de mitu
aujourd'hui si la question de l'égalité
homme femme est si présente dans notre
espace public dans notre espace
médiatique
c'est grâce à ceux mis tout cela a
permis aux femmes de pouvoir faire part
de leurs voix et c'est ça aussi le
hashtag le hashtag ça peut être la voix
des sans-voix sap est un moment
particulier un moyen particulier
de faire part de quelque chose qui nous
touche profondément et surtout de se
rendre compte qu'on n'est pas seul alors
le hashtag je disais que c'était la voix
des sans voix mais c'est aussi parfois
un cri du coeur c'est ça qui est dingue
aussi avec le hashtag c'est que la
personne qui va le s'en saisir et
l'annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux ne
peut pas imaginer ce qui va se passer
derrière personne ne pouvait imaginer le
mythe où personne ne pouvait imaginer
les révolutions arabes je vous dis ça
cela ne sentent ici pas tout comme
l'histoire de massy ali nejad cette
jeune iranienne qui a vécu dans une
société traditionnelle en iran qui
portent le voile depuis qu'elle est
toute petite elle le dit le hidjab a
fait partie de mon corps et puis qui un
jour en voyage à londres en voyage
universitaire où elle poursuivait ses
études de journalisme
elle a décidé d'enlever son voile et en
enlevant son voile
elle s'est rendu compte qu'elle était en
faite prisonnière de ce morceau de tissu
à ce n'était jamais rendu compte elle
l'a même jamais questionner mais dans
les rues londoniennes
elle s'est prise en photo sans son voile
avec ce vent de liberté qui souffle dans
ses cheveux
en prenant cette photo et en y accolant
hashtag my style si free l'homme ma
liberté furtive
elle a créé une page facebook du même
nom en publiant cette photo et surtout
en encourageant toutes les iraniennes à
faire pareil à se dévoiler à se dévoiler
dans les rues à se dévoiler dans les
campagnes sachant que massy était
abritée à londres mais en iran c'est la
prison à la clef
si jamais les milices tombe sur vous et
d'un coup ça n'a pas été dit ni sang ni
1000 mais des centaines de milliers de
photos comme celle ci où les femmes se
sont dévoilés et ont nourri cette page
facebook my style si free dom alors
attention qu'on soit bien clair
maciel est née jeanne n'est pas contre
le voile à l'est contre l'obligation du
port du voile et après elle ce sont même
les hommes qui s'y sont mis cela n'a pas
elle ne sont pas été les men in black
mais les mannini jabbes et pour les
hommes ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est qu'ils disent ben tiens moi je
vais porter le voile pour donner le
droit à ma femme de ne pas le porter et
les hommes sont embarqués dans ce grand
mouvement
qui a été massif alors forcément massy
ali nejad lorsque les autorités
iraniennes commence à voir cette page
facebook avec ses centaines de milliers
de photos ils essayent de la fermer elle
renaît sur instagram et puis elle se
retrouve un peu dans les radars donc le
gouvernement a fait passer par le régime
plutôt a fait passer de folles rumeurs
la concernant c'est une prostituée c'est
un agent de la cia pour tenter de la
discréditer
mais rien rien n'y a fait les photos ont
continué à arriver arrive est arrivé
jusqu'à encore aujourd'hui et puis basta
immédiate s'est dit ça il faut que je
transforme un petit peu mon mouvement
pour arriver à concerner les femmes qui
portent le voile mais qui nous
soutiennent alors à la l'idée du white
wells dès mercredi blanc les mercredis
blanc le concept est simple si une femme
porte le voile qu'elle porte un voile
blanc et en portant un voile blanc
cela signifie qu'elle nous soutienne et
puis surtout c'était une manière
d'arriver à se mobiliser sans être
intercepté par le pouvoir puisque on a
le droit de porter le voile
mais si les blancs cela veut dire que
ces femmes sont prêtes encourage veulent
que d'autres femmes aient le droit de ne
pas le porter en iran les white way they
sont rendus connu aussi avec cette jeune
femme qui tient donc son voile blanc au
bout de son bâton et qui est devenue par
la suite une icône et qui a même fait la
prison cette femme elle a été emprisonné
plusieurs semaines justement pour avoir
fait ce geste et c'est grâce à la
mobilisation nationale mais aussi
internationale c'est grâce à toutes ces
femmes qui ont posté ses photos sur la
page facebook qu'elle a pu être libéré
et surtout c'est grâce à ce mouvement là
aujourd'hui
l'iran est totalement bouleversée entre
le régime des mollahs entre son histoire
ses traditions mais aussi cette jeunesse
qui a soif d'émancipation qui a soif de
liberté
qui aurait pu imaginer en 2014 quand
massy ali nejad fait cette photo dans
les rues londoniennes
qui aurait pu imaginer que cela suscite
un mouvement d'une telle ampleur
personnes vous voyez c'est ça aussi la
magie du hashtag cela ne sentent ici pas
il faut que ça soit authentique il faut
que ça soit ce cri du coeur
tout comme celui d'alicia garza alicia
garza aller à auckland en train de boire
une bière avec ses copines on est donc
aux états unis il ya une télévision qui
tourne en boucle juste à côté et
hambourg à la prend que la justice
acquitté georges zimmerman qui était une
sorte de gardien de résidence presque un
milicien gardant de résidence qui avait
été accusé d'avoir tué et qui a tué
d'ailleurs très ivan martin un jeune
noire de 17 ans il était parmi les juges
ont considéré que cet acte là était de
la légitime défense
mais quel est son crime à ce jeune
américain afro-américain de 17 ans est
juste d'être noir et de se balader dans
une résidence pour blanc sauf que la
peur du noir est elle aux états unis que
zimmerman a été acquitté pour alicia car
ça à ce moment là c'est c'est la goutte
d'eau
c'est l'injustice de trop alors elle
prend son téléphone
elle prend sa plume numérique et elle
écrit une lettre sur facebook elle écrit
black people peuple noir
je vous aime je nous aime la vie des
noirs compte et à ce moment là
patrice q lors ce qui est une amie
militante qui se retrouve à los angeles
va lui répondre
blacklight matters la vie des noirs
comptent ce black l'animateur va
instantanément devenir un hashtag qui va
se répandre et sur facebook et surtout
sur twitter ce black clouds matters va à
ce moment-là devenir l'endroit où tous
les afro américains pour dire moi aussi
j'ai été arrêté de manière quasiment
illégale sans motif j'ai vu une violence
policière
à côté de moi j'ai pris mon téléphone je
les filme et cette vidéo je la publie
blacklight matters peu de temps après
opale tome et y va compléter ce qui va
devenir un trio au paletot mé i ll via
new york c'est une geek et elle va
mettre en ligne une plateforme pour
justement recueillir tous ces
témoignages de ces jeunes noirs comme
blancs qui dénoncent ces violences
policières et blacklight matters va
devenir une association va devenir des
antennes qui vont même se monter dans
plusieurs villes des états unis et dans
le monde entier
blacklight matters est quelque part une
résurgence du combat des droits civiques
de martin luther king dans les années 60
c'est quelque chose d'aussi fort sauf
que à la différence du combat de martin
luther king
ce mouvement et plus inclusif plus
féminin plus queer et surtout il ne
repose pas sur le culte de la
personnalité
du pasteur comme disent les trois filles
on préfère dix mille bougies à un seul
phare et cette phrase-là symbolisme
totalement le mouvement black
l'animateur et symbolise aussi ce que
les réseaux sociaux peuvent offrir de
meilleures une dernière bougie et j'en
finirai avec elle s'appelle april wine
en 2015 dans la même mouvance que blake
lively matters al assiste à la
télévision ou aux nominations des oscars
des oscars 2015 qu'est ce qui se passe à
ce moment là 100% des nominations des
nommés sont blancs sont caucasien 100%
et sa pensée que les comédiennes où les
comédiens afro américains n'ont pas de
talent ou alors que hollywood et raciste
à ce moment là a pris les rênes à lens
un hashtag oscars so wait
c'est fort c'est impactant c'est
toujours un vent marin oscars so wait
elle lance ce hashtag pour pointer du
doigt ce qu'elle considère être comme
une forme de racisme
conscient ou inconscient on en parle un
peu les gens voler ce hashtag et puis il
tombe un petit peu dans les limbes dans
l'oubli du net 2016
oscar toujours saison 2 pourrait-on dire
de nouveau une nomination 100% blanche
là c'est plus possible c'est plus
possible autant l'année dernière ça
pouvait être un malheureux hasard
là ça veut dire quelque chose il ya
quelque chose qui ne fonctionne pas dans
cette société américaine donc à ce
moment-là ce hashtag ressurgit run est
une sorte de résurrection de sauce car
ce white qui va être repris par des
stars engagées comme spike lee comme
michael moore comme george clooney qui
eux l'ont menacé de boycotter la
cérémonie
donc ça y est à ce moment-là hollywood
ne peut plus fermer les yeux
donc voyez dans la mécanique il faut que
la taxe soit authentique un cri du coeur
et ensuite qui les calculs relais
d'opinion pour véritablement émergé
c'est ce qui se passe avec oscar ce
white hollywood est donc obligé de
constater qu'il ya un problème et son
action va permettre de repenser le mode
de nomination de l'académie des oscars
ses 6700 membres l'académie des oscars
6700 membres dont 94% de personnes
d'origine caucasienne dont la très
grande majorité sont des hommes et dont
la très grande majorité ont plus de 50
ans
donc forcément ces gens là
on pense des gens qui leur ressemblent
donc grâce à l'action d'un fils wayne
grâce au scandale que ça a suscité
aujourd'hui l'académie a changé et alain
inclut des membres des votants en
fonction de différents quotas ça vaut
aux etats unis ils n'ont pas de problème
avec les quotas et quelque part
l'efficacité a été immédiate puisque
l'année suivante en 2017
on a eu le film moonlight est notamment
le réalisateur barry jenkins qui a été
récompensé on a eu une actrice est un
acteur afro américains qui ont été
récompensés et les oscars ont enfin un
peu ouvert les yeux sur cette situation
une nouvelle fois qui aurait pu imaginer
et sans doute pas april wine qui était
une simple militante 1,6 recettes pas
quelqu'un qui avait une grande influence
qui aurait pu imaginer qu'en lançant ce
hashtag oscars ce white cela permet a
permis cela permettrait aujourd'hui
d'avoir changé totalement le mode de
répartition de l'académie des oscars
donc c'est ça que j'essaye de vous faire
comprendre c'est que ces hashtag c'est
quelque chose de magique et je
terminerai avec cette dernière idée en
parlant de facebook puisque j'ai ouvert
cette intervention avec facebook qui
peut évidemment être le théâtre le
théâtre de l'horreur et de la barbarie
on s'en est rendu compte encore hier
avec ce terroriste qui a diffusé cette
vidéo de 17 minutes sanglante terroriste
australien en nouvelle zélande où il a
battu 49% dans deux mosquées donc
facebook ça peut être ça facebook ça
peut aussi être cette lettre d'amour
écrite par elsie regardera ça peut aussi
être ces femmes iraniennes qui se libère
bref les réseaux sociaux sont un outil
et les réseaux sociaux sont ce que nous
en faisons donc
charge à nous d'utiliser notre courage
notre bienveillance notre solidarité
pour rendre le monde meilleur
nous en sommes capables et je dirais
même c'est notre responsabilité
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]